[Music]
inside a 3-2 play shooting just 40%
[Applause]
very time to the gentleman I don't care
in the underarm card with you or not
18
I see
it off and you can see him here he goes
takes it and shoe that was to get out of
his hands and when dip dunk that
whips it knocked away by Davis shop box
still winding Davis comes up with it
[Applause]
and just like that all of LeBrons work
and the calves worked in this Forge and
Doug New Orleans is back on top by one
Dave is able to collect by a tenth of a
second field spacing nobody there bought
a 380
[Applause]
when they see that and we might see it
all night long that's fairly aggressive
he doesn't move doesn't always show in
numbers over Cooper's Robertson nice
kids Anthony Davis is special yes it was
Anthony Davis a lot of people don't
forget it it's just 19 years old
Drew's got Alfred and he's got a V on
the trail
[Applause]
we don't was going hard
fortunately a good landing like this
[Applause]
I can take a few more about Putin's face
he like that for in his own pocket over
the top
[Applause]
and what about cousin's response this is
not the all-star game
racial
twenty-six-year-old from serbia mention
something we were talking about that's
not good
[Music]
[Applause]
sir Anthony Davis is on fire a memorable
one for 18 that's what
so you're not going to get it papers it
[Applause]
the recipient and hopefully he's okay I
think we may see him on the TV in the
morning
stitch me back yes Wow